le petit à causeur de transformers l'âge
de l'extinction un an avant la sortie de
jurassic world et huit ans avant que le
monde d'après fasse apparaître dans la
saga jurassic world son premier
dinosaure à plumes la saga transformers
dans son quatrième film avait fait
apparaître un dinosaure à plumes avec
les plumes correctement positionné il
s'agit de psittacosaurus un petit
dinosaure de la famille des cératopsidés
qui vivait au crétacé en mongolie et
dont les plumes sont représentés simple
et filamenteuses est positionné à la
base de la queue exactement comme c'est
le cas sur le fossile alors c'est quand
même pas anodin en 2014 d'avoir choisir
un petit dinosaure pas un gros un
herbivore pas un carnivore qui vient
d'asie et non pas d'amérique du nord
pour figurer dans ces quelques premières
minutes de cette introduction du film
transformers 4
c'est pas anodin parce qu'en 2014 sitac
aux russes ils n'étaient pas aussi bien
connu qu'il l'est aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui psittacosaurus c'est devenu
une star parmi les dinosaures en partie
grâce au film transformers 4 mais
surtout par la recherche qui a été
conduite sur psittacosaurus et qui a
montré la préservation de la peau à tel
point que maintenant on est capable de
dire quelle est l anatomie exacte du
cloaque de psittacosaurus et qu'on a
même un article qui est sorti récemment
montrant qu'il avait une cicatrice qui
correspond à son cordon ombilical
j'utilise des guillemets évidemment pas
de cordon ombilical pour les animaux qui
naissent dans un oeuf mais qui est la
cicatrice qui correspond à la connexion
avec l'oeuf donc psittacosaurus c'est à
dinosaures qui maintenant est devenue
célèbre mais en 2014 il n'était pas
aussi célèbre qu'il l'est aujourd'hui
donc c'est un choix plutôt osée d'avoir
fait figurer psittacosaurus dans cette
introduction du quatrième épisode de la
saga transformers mais c'est un choix
encore plus osées de l'avoir représenté
anatomiquement juste anatomiquement
correct au moins sur la position des
plumes ce que ne fera pas la saga
jurassic world avant jurassique world e3
jurassique world 2 1 aurait mis des
plumes à ces dinosaures j'aurai à ledit
jurassique worlds ii aurait mis des
plumes à ces dinosaures quatre ans plus
tard j'aurais dit c'est pas trop tôt
mais quand seulement huit ans après
michael bay jurassique world 3 mai des
plumes sur ces dinosaures alors je suis
désolé je ne leur donnerai pas un
susucre pour avoir réussi à faire ce que
michael bay a fait presque dix ans plus
tôt alors non la saga jurassic world
n'est pas une série de documentaires
mais pas plus que ne l'est la saga
transformers et contrairement à la saga
jurassic world transformers n'avait pas
un paléontologue comme conseiller
scientifique donc la saga transformers
n'a jamais eu comme argument de vente la
justesse de ces dinosaures alors
évidemment ce psittacosaurus il n'est
pas parfait on notera qu'il est plutôt
maigrichon et qu'il allait la paume des
maquis et tourné vers le bas mais j'ai
envie de dire que de ce point de vue là
il ne fait que suivre un standards
esthétiques qui a été établie par la
saga jurassic park et qui a été ensuite
continué par la saga jurassic world donc
de ce point de vue là ce psittacosaurus
n'est pas pire que ce qu'on voit dans
jurassic ward est évidemment il y a le
poisson à ce fameux poisson que
psittacosaurus est en train de manger
alors que psittacosaurus hante encore
nitti chien était un herbivore comme je
les dis alors voir un ornithischiens
piscivores à l'écran pourrait être
considéré comme une sacrée entorse au
réalisme de notre psittacosaurus et
pourtant en 2016 donc seulement deux ans
après la sortie de transformers 4 eh
bien on va découvrir que liaoning aux
eaux russes un autre ornithischiens
d'asie un an kilos d'or était en réalité
piscivores liaoning aux russes a été
découvert avec des restes de poissons
dans son estomac démontrant que les
ornithischiens pouvait faire des
entorses à leur régime alimentaire
strictement herbivores et de temps en
temps et bien se nourrir de poisson du
reste les entorses à un régime
strictement herbivores ne sont pas peu
commune chez les herbivores modernes que
sont les ruminants par exemple michael
bay dans sa saga transformers a donc
anticipé de deux ans la découverte que
les ornithischiens pouvait faire des en
temps ça leur régime alimentaire
herbivores et se nourrir de poissons et
si ça avait été dans la saga jurassic
park j'aurais moi-même crier au génie ce
n'était donc que justice ce que de faire
moi aussi une petite entorse à ma règle
habituelle est de vous parler pour une
fois d'un film qui n'appartient pas à la
saga jurassic park et qui démontre qu'un
film peut être à la fois être un
divertissement que la plupart des gens
considèrent comme décérébrés et pourtant
faire des propositions de dinosaures qui
sont scientifiquement correcte